we mentioned earlier that the delta
variant of the coronavirus continues to
drive up infections in this country but
in britain the focus has turned to that
omicron variant we learned this morning
that the first patient has died from
omicron in the u.k as charlie dagetta
reports the government is now taking
steps to fight the fast spreading new
variant
britain is back on a full frontal covet
attack
with health officials warning that the
omicron variant is spreading at a
phenomenal rate but i need to speak to
you this evening a national address from
the prime minister in a public plea to
get booster shots
no one should be in any doubt there is a
tidal wave of omicron coming and i'm
afraid it is now clear that two doses of
vaccine are simply not enough to give
the level of protection we all need
he's ordered britain's national health
service to ramp up to a million booster
shots a day which may not sound much in
a country as big as the us but it's a
tall order here the highest one day
total ever reached back in march was
just under 850 thousand strict new
lockdown restrictions went into place
today with the government again issuing
work from home orders in addition to
broader mass mandates in public places
and events that went into effect over
the weekend and they're voting on
whether to require covid passports to
gain admission to places like nightclubs
by taking the action now you know sooner
rather than later the type of action
that we set out the working from home
the the rules on the face masks the the
use of the nhs code passport we can
avoid further action later because this
does bias time this morning the prime
minister said at least one person has
already died of the omicron variant and
the infection rate is doubling every two
to three days
for cbs mornings charlie dagetta london